quando ero piccolo ragazzo cavo che le
sono solo qua perché va beh un reperto
storico bra giocavo con il game boy
advance io avevo questa specie di
quadrato stupido parte pokémon che va bè
quello di fans di tutti ci sono stati
altri due giochi per il game boy che
gioca un sacco quando ero piccolo non so
per quanto più province hanno un motto
forse perché erano giochi prende menti
che bella scritta nintendo in hd
ecco perché adesso le future perché mi
piace la nostra europa lasciando stare
che p è veramente più pixelloso di
qualsiasi roba vi faccio vedere in cosa
consiste prime te tu scegli una sfida di
queste ok
devi fare le robe il tempo è una cosa
idiota premi mi divertivo come un
bambino forse perché era un bambino sono
troppo portale per niente devo fare le
robe prima che scada il tempo dei
ragazzi 21 sarà record di questo gioco
che rende ragazzi sto gioco sembra una
stronzata
non fate commenti vi prego no al mercato
io sono morto ma porca eva lo sapevo 23
lite sono durato ben sei tanto comunque
ricorda non ricordo se veramente
bastardissimo studenti bisogna e ti fai
tin un floppy bird fatti sono un
fenomeno e tipo un floppy bird però di
mille anni fa è fighissimo
se vi rendete conto della malattia e io
la partita per invece di andare a scuola
fingevo di avere la febbre giocava sta
roba ve lo giuro
c'era il bruciore una malattia ma che
fenomeno madonna una donna un fenomeno
e vabbè un fenomeno 65
ora è che non è arrivato lo si nota te
lo giuro
se neanche quando ero piccolo mi piace
niente troppo break e l'aveva qua non ci
passo mai
[Musica]
guardali guardali guarda libica che
carica ma torna la conferma abbiamo
giura salvario 118 non solo caricando
così avanti nel punto picco perché parlo
porca eva ragazzi proviamo a fare quello
della ragazza che i mona si chiama mona
vabbè gelateria mona no no no no vai
mona no no no no time on april consegna
il gelato in motorino con questa
splendida vista in hd a malapena si
capisce che quella è una persona va
veloce quindi la polizia la segue
praticamente la gara anche è anche un
gioco diseducativo questo va beh ma
chissenefrega tanto
e mentre la culla la segue io devo
giocare viggiano che non è non ha un
senso che si sa cosa fare e non potevo
sbagliare quella dove dovevo arrotolare
gli spaghetti scusami sono italiano e 3
grande gioco bellissimo questo sia un
fenomeno che sarà questo va però troppo
bravo a prescindere 5
[Musica]
ma quella della demenzialità dei giochi
raga quanto sono difficili quelli limone
anni giochi prego fenomeno un fenomeno
sono in fila a questo sono diventato
bravo col tempo possa stage dove sono
arrivati al boss tragga qui a 15 ha già
che il boss era era col martello è la
cosa più della vita
[Musica]
non sono capace attaccare i quadri
questo capace neanche adesso 14 mobile
ai ragazzi il programma fa regimi
l'ultimo jimmy e jimmy non avete idea di
quanto sia un frigo jimmy e per chi non
conoscesse lui che è uomo che charme che
portamento guardano le leve del agiscono
senza capelli ma con una parrucca che
caparezza in confronto niente spacca ok
ha quindi armi attraverso il telefono
perfetto a ogni mini gioco che faccio un
messaggio in più che gli arrivava bene
[Musica]
è in culo la nordcorea bravo zio bravo
schiva cantante troiane si sono
inventate la madonna bebè l'asta sketch
ho fatto la schiacciata nella vita reale
quando arrivò minchia un'ora un'ora per
il boss dai mi ricordo cosa era ga.am e
weather contro mcgregor ai ha accusato
farlo schivare io ok video già mi sono
preso due schiaffi del sedere montoli
incredibile
[Musica]
mi.va contro l'inter
vabbè raga mi è venuta in mente una cosa
tra l'altro che mi ricordo che c'è
perché ci ho giocato troppo asso gioco
una roba che ti fa fare solo i box ed
era fichissimo sono boss
eccolo noi chiama lo ricordavo
addirittura per cento grazie ci ho
giocato ti fa fare solo le cose dei boss
in ordine
[Musica]
ok ok è il primo voce andato ko questo
abbia appena fatto corsa al diavolo è
sta roba mica chi se lo ricordava mentre
sembra tutto il jumper dunque ragazzi
secondo me mario è il precursore di un
miliardo di giochi che hanno fatto
successo poi molti anni dopo tipo doodle
jump tipo troppi bird e anche
dell'incazzatura che mi sarei preso il
futuro porca eva che bella musica poi
[Musica]
tete a tete michela sua memoria va da
una volta si è giocata sta roba perso
l'impiego perché sono così rincoglionito
al giorno d'oggi perché ho passato
l'infanzia così con il monte fuji dietro
che può accompagnare solo e il giappone
in questi giorni e più vicino che mai
basta quanto tempo guarda quante ore sta
saltando basta poi in una vasca verdi di
gelatina però lui è contento va bene ai
bis con 50
[Musica]
ma questa è una malattia ma la gente in
pena di morte la chiudono giocherà sta
roba cosa minchia è ma neanche i malati
di mente che stanno per morire domani e
bello se ps in finte come conta sentite
la cucina che non sta dicendo nessun
numero è sporca o è sì o no io devo
battere 50 dell'obante va bene la
carriera la uk permier assicurata già da
bambino come potevo creare un canale più
demenziali di quello che ho dopo aver
giocato a sta merda
quanto costano è giocata ci ho trovato
toppa che do
[Musica]
adesso ha cambiato voce adesso canta a
caso a volte la girano lenta volte
veloce madonna che brutto un giorno
quando sono bravo ragazzo
[Musica]
vabbè è figura
mi chiamo 80 va bene l'aria basta con
tanto di sigla di amici di maria de
filippi che hanno copiato da wario ma
nessuno mai se n'è accorto perché di
casa sono ancora la boario spero che vi
sia piaciuto un tuffo nel passato per me
incredibile non avete idea di quanto sia
figo permette che la sta roba veramente
anche infanzia stata questa non vi
stupite sono dei problemi adesso però vi
sia piaciuto come sotto servito un
commento non mi piace anche adesso
cercano del tiziano si rischia tre ci
mettiamo prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]